Good evening.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy.
I hope it has been happy.
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambodassa.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and self-awakened one.
I thought this evening we'd change tack a little bit.
This is the discourse of Jivaka.
Jivaka, it seems, was found on a rubbish heap
by a certain prince and was brought up he went off to a university in takasila which was at that time very famous up in present-day um pakistan part of the old uh greek empire i think and he became a doctor a very successful doctor so let's see what this is about
Thus have I heard on one occasion the blessed one was living at Rajagaha in the mango grove of Jivaka Kumbarabacha.
Now the Rajagaha, remember, is Rajgir, the city of the king, which is where Bimbisara, one of his great supporters, one of his great supporters lived.
So that was the country right on the Ganges, Varanasi, that sort of area.
And Jivaka by this time has become quite rich, so he owns a mango grove.
Jivaka went to see the Blessed One and paid homage, sat to one side and said, Venerable Sir, I've heard this.
They slaughter living beings for the recluse Gautama.
The recluse Gautama knowingly eats meat prepared for him from animals killed for his sake.
Do these speak as you say?
Sorry.
Do those who speak thus say what has been said by the Blessed One and not misrepresent him?
And then there's this lovely sentence, which we had, yes, these pastimes.
Do they explain in accordance with the Dhamma in such a way that nothing which provides a ground for censure
can be legitimately deduced from their assertions.
I can't imagine the ordinary person saying that.
Jivaka, those who speak thus do not say what has been said by me, but misrepresent me with what is untrue and contrary to fact.
I say there are three instances in which meat should not be eaten.
when it is seen, heard or suspected that the living being has been slaughtered for a monastic.
So now he's talking about rules for monastics.
I say that meat should not be eaten on these three instances.
I say there are three instances in which meat can be eaten when it is not seen, not heard, not suspected that the living being has been slaughtered for the bhikkhu.
or the monastic.
And I say that meat may be eaten in these three instances.
So now there we have a sort of basic attitude to meat, to meat eating.
Now, we have to remember that in the Buddha's time, there were famines.
And when there was a famine, you killed your livestock, you know.
It also really shows the Buddha as the great pragmatist.
If he had absolutely said that everybody had to be vegetarian who followed him, then it would be very difficult to spread the Dharma to people who live in desert regions or up in the Arctic.
And what do you say to an Inuit?
Eat snow.
So there's something about the Buddha that never takes him towards an idealism.
And the reason is that the world is relative.
You can't make absolute laws in a relative universe.
So it's not thou shalt not kill, it's I undertake the training rule not to kill living beings, right?
So there's always this understanding in the Buddha that there are times when obvious rules, moral laws, have to be, shall we say, understood for a greater purpose.
have to be put aside for a greater purpose.
I remember, you know, at school, they used to say, they used to give you these little problems like, if you're starving, would it be right to steal food, you see?
I think most people would say yes, except from somebody who's worse off than you, who's actually on the point of death.
That wouldn't be right, would it?
So these are the three rules.
We'll carry on.
I mean, it now goes slightly off piste a bit from eating meat.
But he said a monk or a monastic who lives in dependence of a certain village or town.
And his practice is loving kindness.
He abides with loving kindness to all beings before him, behind him, etc.
Then a householder comes to him and invites him for the next day's meal.
And the monk, the monastic accepts it if he likes.
When the night is ended in the morning, he dresses and taking his bowl and outer robe, goes to the house of that householder and sits down on a seat made ready.
The householder's son arrives and serves him with good food.
He does not think, see, the monastic does not think, how good that householder serves me with good alms food.
If only the householder might serve me with such good alms food in the future.
He does not think thus.
He eats that alms food without being tied to it, infatuated with it and utterly committed to it, seeing the danger in it and understanding the escape from it.
In other words, to renounce that greediness.
So what do you think, Jivaka?
Would that monastic on such an occasion choose for his own affliction or for another's affliction or for the affliction of both?
No, Venerable Sir.
Does not that monastic sustain himself with blameless food on that occasion?
Yes, Venerable Sir, I've heard this.
Brahma abides in loving kindness, in other words,
Having developed that loving kindness, he's not going to be greedy.
It undermines greed.
The Blessed One is my visible witness to this.
The Blessed One abides in loving kindness.
And then Jivaka, any lust, any hate, any delusion whereby ill will might arise has been abandoned by the Tathagata, cut off at the root, made a palm stump, done away with, so that they are no longer subject to future arising.
If what you said referred to that, then I allow it to you.
Yes, I referred to precisely that.
So here we have a teaching about not being greedy with food, not expecting the food to be always wonderful and the same, even if you cook it for yourself, not to get attached to food.
And a statement about the Buddha himself, that he doesn't suffer from greediness or anything like that.
And then there's that repetition of that.
Repetition of that whole business of going to a householder's house, et cetera, et cetera.
Then he says, and on that occasion, would he, you know, on such an occasion, would his eating be blameless?
So we can presume here that he's also been offered meat and so forth.
uh so then he says well it's also said that brahma abides in equanimity so this is another quality that you have to develop in order to undermine greed not become attached to it any lust any hatred any delusion whereby cruelty discontent or aversion might arise has been abandoned by the targeter he's talking about himself now so cruelty of course is um the end is replaced by compassion um
discontent by joy and uh equanimity aversion by equanimity uh i had a little experience of this myself when i went to sri lanka i went back to sri lanka and i've been in england for a little while and i went to the international buddhist meditation center which is in um
which is in Colombo, and was actually maybe built, I think it was built for the Mohasi in the middle 50s by Bandra Naik, who were prime ministers then.
And every day somebody would come and offer food.
They had enough support for one particular family for about a month.
So every day for a month you would get people coming, you see.
And I got it into my head as to why, you know, they didn't serve me, being a Westerner, why they didn't serve me some Western food.
And it became a sort of silly obsession in my head, you see, because I know that one dish that the Sri Lankans like is macaroni cheese.
So I got into this and slowly over a period of four or five days, I got quite averse to the food that they were giving me.
And I could hear this whinging mind, you know, and all that sort of stuff going on, you see.
And it got to a point where I suddenly realized, what am I doing?
You know, these people are offering me food.
I'm not paying for it.
I'm not, you know, it's a gift.
And here I am complaining, you see.
So I began, of course, then to develop gratitude, you see, and as I developed the gratitude, it's wonderful how amazing the food began to taste.
So your taste is actually, you know, affected, your taste buds, I think, are affected by how you feel towards the food or the people who are offering you the food.
So these three things, you see, a sense of compassion for the person who's offering you the food, a sense of joy at receiving it, reciprocal joy, because it's also in terms of an offering.
If somebody invites you around for a meal, it's an offering to you and they're joyful in offering it to you and you rejoice in their joy.
You're happy because they're happy.
And underlying all that is this sense of equanimity so that you don't get greedy.
uh then then there's a final uh paragraph here concerning the slaughters so if anyone slaughters a living being for the tatagata or his disciple and he lay he lays up much demerit in five instances when he says go and fetch the living being when the living being experiences pain and grief by being led by uh with a neck halter
when he says go and slaughter the living being when the living being experiences pain and grief on being slaughtered and when he provides that the targeter or his disciples with food that is not permissible these are the five um things that bring much demerit in these five inch instances
so it and as you see at any of that point somebody who recognize or realize what they're doing could stop you see as they you know as they call for the animal they could then say no no that wouldn't be right i'm killing it purposely for these monastics and so at each of those stages they can stop and each of those stages if they stop the earlier they stop the less demerit right that's the idea of always splitting up an action
There was a lovely occasion at the Birmingham Buddhist Vihara where there was a few of us in the meditation hall.
And the whole question of vegetarianism came up, you see.
And in the East, or should we say, generally speaking, they make a clear distinction between the butcher who actually kills the meat.
and therefore must have aversion in their minds and the people who eat it who haven't got aversion they just got greed right so therefore they're not so uh they don't they don't have so much demerit should we say so it's all right to eat meat you see because you didn't actually kill the animal so of course we argued with venerable dr tadama whom some of you i'm sure met uh that of course
every time you buy the meat you're paying the butcher to kill another animal right i mean the shelf has to be replenished in the shops and uh it took him a long time you know he wouldn't he wouldn't agree to that because because of this fixation about the butcher is the one who really commits the deed and for which there's real bad news but the person who eats the meat well he can he can just be greedy you just have to be greedy i mean after all it's just
Dead meat is food.
The connection between the buyer of the food and the butcher is just not there, you see.
But eventually we got through to him, I think, and he agreed that there was some connection there, you see, some karmic connection.
Anyway, not long after that, I think it was probably the weekend, I had to go down to London with him.
And we got there quite early and we went for a sort of brunch.
And we went to a little cafe that is near the Victoria bus station.
And we walked in and we ordered breakfast, you see.
And of course, I ordered vegetarian breakfast and he ordered bacon, sausage and eggs.
And he gave me a very sheepish look.
So even though he had begun to understand there was some sort of connection there, he was still hanging on to the old ways of thinking about these things.
So that does present us as Buddhists, as followers of the Dharma, with some reflection there.
It's interesting that in Buddhist countries, if you are a butcher or a fisherman, you tend to be looked down upon because you kill meat, because you kill living beings rather.
And when I was told that in Sri Lanka, when the Christians came, it was easy to convert the fishermen along the seaboard because, of course, they said, well, Jesus caught fish.
He actually helped people to catch fish.
And so it alleviated them of this constant guilt.
It's funny how it's easy to place the culpability on somebody else and make them feel completely guilty because you're eating the fish.
So anyway, Jivaka then says that he wants to become a lay follower who's gone for refuge for life.
Actually, this must be a little addition at the end because he's already become a follower.
Jeevaka actually became the main doctor, became the doctor for Bimbisara and for the Buddha.
He was an extremely clever doctor.
And what happened was, of course, you had to pay him, you see.
And what happened was, because of his reputation, people who were ill would join the order, you see, join the order.
and then say that, you know, express their sickness, tell them about their sickness to get cured, and then they leave, you see.
And Jiva could, of course, when he found this out, ask the Buddha not to allow that.
So there came a rule.
There's a rule that you cannot enter the monastic order, the Buddhist monastic orders, if you're ill, if you've got an illness, right?
I mean, I'm not talking about the cold or something, but some illness which needs to be cured.
which can be cured.
And eventually it's down to the group of monks or nuns, actually, as to whether they would let somebody in who has some physical disability of some sort.
Not so much disability as an illness.
Yeah.
So I hope this has given you some food for thought, the Jivaka discourse on vegetarianism.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance and that by your effort and practice you will become liberated sooner rather than later.
So we can begin a little practice.